okay
uh sorry we're starting a little late
for people who are on this live stream
we are talking about some uh synthetic
geometry for version 12.2
okay so first point here
in what sense why should i care that
this is now
a um a dynamic module
uh because now the uh you can
dynamically move the points
so if you okay so i
guess i probably should have looked at
the
agenda but right the the whole
experience is
has been completely changed so maybe
we should open up a a master or a 12-1
so you can sort of compare no i remember
what the
i mean this is spectacular you can
essentially do constrained drawing here
correct okay now now here the canvas
didn't reset
the canvas could have reset why didn't
it um
so basically um
there's options for if you want to have
certain points fixed um
so you know since this is constrained
drawing if you move a point you might
have to move other points to
uh um to continue
to satisfy the constraints however you
do have the
option to have certain points
fixed um when a when a point is moved so
that it doesn't uh
it won't move how does the resize work
can i resize the whole thing oh yeah the
plus minus in the lower corner no that's
not what i mean i mean resize the image
on the screen
i think if you uh
drag the lower right corner
isn't that uh no it's not we should make
it be
be draggable in the lower right corner
we should we should indicate it with
little
little ridges and we should make it be
draggable
okay
wow how complicated can i do this for
more complicated theorems
uh yeah so the um
since it is dynamic um
if the if it's complicated enough it
will
uh time out i think i set the timeout
for
10 seconds maybe um
so um you know the
it it depends on the computation what
does paul's updates do
so this is if you want to move multiple
points at once
so i think that's a very confusing name
um
but i don't know exactly what it should
be
um
but so essentially what you've done here
um
okay brian on a live stream is saying it
should have a recenter button that puts
the diagram back in the center of the
window i agree that's a good idea right
i think that's just a plus minus we
should have something with an icon
that indicates you know re-centering
okay yeah i think that would probably
uh yes that would be that would be fun
okay but so
um don't say i wouldn't say fixed points
because that's
confusing whether it's going in or
coming out and we would say
um keep fixed colon
and then each one of these in a sense
i mean it's like a check mark which one
of these do we want to keep fixed
points kept fixed
well maybe there are other things that
you can keep fixed like a distance and
so on as well
uh yes there are so
it uh um if there are any user
provided points or quantities that you
open the first
in the first argument can be selected to
being
as being fixed so to be clear
if it's selected as fixed and you move
that point it'll still
move it's only fixed if you try to move
something else and we say okay this is
this is now anchored i think we
previously
maybe called those anchor anchors but uh
um nobody understood that yeah no one
understands
but again fixing nobody understood this
either because if you say it's fixed and
then i move it
it's like hello right um
okay so what really is it it's it's that
if you move another point those points
will try to
stay fixed if you move another point
well they will stay fixed if you move
another point they will stay fixed
what happens if i move to the point
where it's not possible
then it will go back to where it will
think about it and when it figures out
that it can't do it it'll
reset right it'll how does it
how does it okay so can
can we indicate that somehow here
you'll need another you'll need to fix
another point like fix
if you fix a and c and then you
or is that really no that's probably
not uh well so if you fix a c and o then
the the
the circle is fixed so then you could
move b outside the circle and it
wouldn't be able to satisfy it
so it would try for a few seconds and
then
give up and move b back
this is very weird this is like the
halting problem in action
okay at the point where it moves it back
here's what i think you should do i
think you should have something which
shows where you tried to put it
and then puts a dotted line back to
where it had to go
how do you get rid of this
you move it again
or alternatively you
maybe you put a ghost of it where you
thought you put it
i think you have a ghost and then it's
it has a
line going back to where it had to go to
and how long would this line stay up
until the next time you try to move
something
that's what i'm thinking yeah that seems
weird i have to say well how else would
you make it go away
well that's what i'm well either it
could be there
i mean i suppose there could be uh could
be another button
yeah well i just want to say i suppose
there might be
we could like animate it coming back
rather you know what you know
that's that's overlay a lot but why
don't we just do the following
when you requested something yes i think
michael is right
that it it says um
you know something like clear placement
and you put the b there and it's then
just ghosted out in the place where you
put it but it moves back over here
and then
actually i mean if if we had something
in there um
we could um uh so brian is suggesting
click anywhere in the window to dismiss
the ghost
not totally crazy the other possibility
is that on the ghost itself you click
the ghost itself and it goes away
the ghost itself could have an x button
you see what i'm saying all right i
guess my question is what is the
purpose of having the ghost there just
to
show that you tried it and it didn't
work yes because otherwise if
you know when you're moving a large
distance it's fairly obvious what
happened
if it moved just a tiny distance it
would be much less obvious what happened
well i want to come back okay so hold on
a second i just want to look at um
um look at this a little bit more i wish
i could make this bigger how would i
make this bigger
tell me how to make this bigger can i
use image size
i do not know i haven't tried this yet
it's it's a dynamic module uh what
magnify
well that would certainly work yeah okay
fine
all right that would work if i just
magnify that cell
ah it's not working why isn't that
working
magnifying the cell didn't work though
what about style i was suggesting using
the magnify function
all right okay
what happened to me here oh what the
hell is that what is that
i think when you started typing earlier
i think you made an underscore
that would be very silly
prototype build yeah
uh yeah in the prototype build i got
commas cause underscores
and maybe other things do too okay
commas produce underscores oh my god
you're right
that was well here let me do this be
clear that's uh
that's not under the purview of this
project
yeah i understand i've got an idea for
how to do this let me let me just do
something incredibly hacky
let's um let's do this
i'm going to go to regular build comma 2
i'm going to copy paste it back over
here
yeah i had to do that basically to
create this notebook
okay better all right
um okay so we we're coming up with
various conclusions here about what we
should do
um
the um
okay so i don't know understand what's
happening here so this point i mean by
the way
have we looked at as the front-end team
looked at the responsiveness here
and i wish we had somebody from do we
have anybody from ux here
this is a quintessential ux problem
no no i think the closest are you brett
and tim
um whom did you have in mind
i wonder if noah is available um
it's a little late in the day for him
but let's see i've asked if we can get
him
okay um
uh there's a question from ali by the
way to
um oh yeah in fact this is a good idea
from
brian here this is a good idea
implicitly when the ghost cannot be met
why not well this is my idea actually
based on his
why not just put a red you know
circle around the point where you put
the point back in the right place put a
red circle around it
with a tool tip that explains it
couldn't be placed
and not put a ghost
and what clears the red circle is moving
it again
would you think moving that particular
point again or moving
any other point any i would i would
think
at any point any point but then then
you're explaining that point
couldn't go in the right place and so
the tool tip explains
the the the position you moved it to
couldn't work
um
okay um
all right let's talk about the uh uh ali
is asking
why would we do synthetic geometry we're
basically working up from
you know the original goal is to take
what euclid did 2000 years ago
and make it computable and that will
gradually work into
constrained drawing and all the all the
things that are
that are useful from that i mean this is
partly just
a sort of a math education thing but
it's also
uh you know given that you have certain
constraints
how do you make a figure that is
consistent with this
is that a fair characterization michael
on others yes
i think that's a good one yeah um
i mean but we're working up from you
know it's non-trivial to even do what
euclid did 2000 years ago
in a fully computable way so that's our
first step here
um okay so let's let's come back to how
this is labeled and so on
all right so why not
is it obvious that we shouldn't just
change the appearance of these points
when they are fixed
with some kind of anchor indicator
um we could do that
uh it seems much clearer than having to
do this
and then then say this how do you get it
to the state
yeah you'd have to click well what you
could do is you could have a menu
that comes up when you when you hover
over a point there could be a little
sub menu that says anchor this point
we'll fix this point yeah i'm saying
right click on it like well nobody's
going to be able to discover right click
okay so it has to fair okay so what it
would be is on hover
but with most of it is a little bit ugly
to turn on and off
if you had like an anchor icon
and if you click the icon itself it
toggles the anchor state
look i think a thing to do would be you
know the obvious thing is to have
some kind of toolbar some kind of
attached cell here which says things
like
removal anchors that's reasonable
but it should be in an attached cell it
shouldn't be part of this so that
so that visually when you see this thing
and that's way too heavy there
when you see this thing visually you
know somebody's going to publish this
in a you know in a in a book or
something you don't want to see all this
fixed points pause updates all that kind
of nonsense there
at the very least what we want is
something which as you go into the
into the area on hover those things come
up and you can click on them
but otherwise it's just a beautiful
picture
that makes sense right there's a remove
uh if you in the upper right hand
that little plus icon um
if you uh
oh yeah hide controls sorry that
um you click something else no i know i
took today
i clicked something for see
unspecified what the heck is this
um sometimes the uh
scene has to generate um
generate its own points if the uh so for
in the
instance here the user didn't actually
specify okay so listen
this this generating points we have this
in modules we have this in axiomatic
theory
um you know we've got to do better than
this approach i think
of a c sub i mean this is this is the
constants that you used to from
integration and things right
right
not really right i mean
well no no i'm not saying that's what's
happening mathematically i'm saying
that's what you're
doing here in this and i'm i'm very
confused by this
this construct here okay well i that
that font is so small that i can't
i i know i know i know i'm going to make
it much bigger
okay i don't exactly know what happened
here we got two cells out what would
what did those two cells mean
did somebody left in a debugging
statement probably
i i'm not exactly sure which you uh
i said does it print the points in the
quantities separately
um i uh it should
i think if you hit points it's just the
points quantities it's just the
quantities and parameters it should be
all together
okay anyway let's go back to the
objectives here okay
so my objective would be the output is
completely beautiful until you hover
over it
and then it has all kinds of controls in
it
okay and when you hover that way we
don't have to compromise
you know we could have even these things
here could come up as visible things if
you hover in the obj
in the in the thing you see what i'm
saying
now realistically when people use this
they're going to be pointing at oh look
at this you know thing
c what does it mean and so on
so
brian is suggesting why not toggle the
anchor with a click
it's not crazy not a crazy idea because
the the pure click right this is why we
need a ux person
um here um the pure click
is you know click drag is different from
click
so we could have a meaning for click
which could mean anchor on anchor
i'm making sense yes that should be
doable
um i don't think i do anything unless
you start to drag
okay fine so let's make that the anchor
on anchor we need iconography for
anchoring anybody got a good iconography
for anchoring
uh either a darker blue or put an edge
form on it
fine let's put an edge form i think it's
better to do an edge form
i think that's and then then there's a
um then then on
on on mouse approach so to speak
we can put a tool tip by the way
somebody's typing we can hear very
clearly
um they uh put a tooltip saying
um you know anchored or something like
that
um
um
um mathematical musings on the live
stream is complaining that the blue
circles cover the actual positions of
the points
yes we consider that i mean this is
already in 12 1 what we have here
and what is the answer to that that
issue
of the fact that the blue circles cover
the points i mean i think i think that's
yes it is true that there is a point
there
usually not an issue unless the points
start interlapping
overlapping yeah i understand i mean
another thing we could do is on hover we
could actually highlight
the dot at the center of these points if
we wanted to we could make these things
go transparent on hover
right which might be interesting we
could also
in the the menu in the upper right have
different view modes where you can just
you know click to get rid of uh point
labels
that's not a bad idea it's not a bad
idea i thought we had discussion the
past some plot theme where yeah
the labels become call outs rather than
at the points
call-outs based on color or something
right i mean if you want yeah currently
if you want something to be
invisible you'd have to do style on the
points but i think i think incorporating
plot themes
into this drop down in the upper right
is probably the
easiest way to do it but that sounds
right to me
okay so let's let's review this okay so
first of all the fixing thing
we agree it's going to be a click and
and
that now um you know what we would need
to do
is
um i think
well seems kind of stupid it isn't um
i think we should have a thing that says
fix points or something or anchor points
in this menu
okay and all it should do is bring up a
dialogue that basically says to fix a
point you click on it
in order to have something discoverable
so this would so this would just be a
uh dial uh just be a information box
yes that's it that's all it would be
it's just otherwise it's not
discoverable
see what i'm saying okay so
let's let's um
what does that do
okay so this this pasting shouldn't be
into three separate cells right i mean
is that just a bug in
in the in this detailed uh yeah
um yeah something uh that should uh
uh normally that's that's a list not
three separate cells i don't know
some kind of bug here yeah um okay why
is the circle through inactivated
because circle through uh issues
messages
if the um uh if
the if it's arguments aren't explicit
coordinates and circle through is not an
inner object right circle through will
actually compute to circle through
as opposed to triangle and line which
are pure symbolic representations
right and because most of our
explicitly behaving functions weren't
coordinates other than symbols for
objects
right
well interesting okay and i assume that
geometric scene perfectly well
takes an activated an activated object
yes
um better check that it does
you can assume it well no it just
makes sure it does i mean it obviously
needs to if it's generating that as
output here
i've got to be able to put this output
back into the input again
right okay okay it doesn't matter just
check that it does we don't need to
discuss it here
there um okay so let's let's come back
to this
so what we're agreeing here is that this
plus minus should appear
on hover if i move into this area then
we should get plus minus
i i don't know what we do for geo plots
what do we do for geoplots if i just say
geographics no dynamic geographic
dynamic geographics has
i think it's it's automatically there
right we base this on dynamic
geographics
stack it the same way did you that
i don't think it should be here except
on hover in this case because
dynamic geographics it's sort of the
main event
right you know
that's the main thing you're seeing here
all right i think maybe before we
completely redesign this
it would be useful to see constructions
and what are some of the other
things you might see here um okay
um i mean so so for example where are
constructions in this notebook because
that's
further down um
uh one other question you mentioned uh
adding to that area where you have the
the plus minus the re-center button um
is there uh you know some sort of symbol
you
yes obviously but it's not the right
group to figure that out yes
there's an obvious re-center thing but
we haven't don't have the right people
to figure it out
um and this pause updates thing we need
a way to
um
again there needs to be a good piece of
iconography i mean the pause updates
is when you want to
when you want to move multiple points at
a time right
correct is that something that can go in
the menu in the top right
no i don't think you want that i think
you want something that allows you
to um that is an icon that means it's
dynamically updating
that comes up on hover and which you can
click
to to toggle off dynamic updating
okay and then it will show up as a
visible thing
that indicates dynamic updating is off
so you know to switch it back on again
that make sense
yeah okay all right let's take a look at
constructions all right
so i let me run this again
actually i realized i couldn't just
expand this window
okay all right so we've got geometric
scene abcd
blah blah blah blah okay so now what's
your point here
right so this is a construction so the
second argument now instead of being a
vector it's a list of vectors
why is this a construction limit that
lists
what what what makes this a construction
uh
rather than being a vector it's a
so the in the first example is a vector
because it's a list of non-list objects
here this is a list of lists i'm sorry
the first
argument the first argument the first
argument
rather than being effective another
second argument
what the hell are you talking about
vector are you talking about the list
the list of lists it's it's vector q
oh not very i don't give a damn about
that i mean what you're saying
are you saying you don't give a damn
about the the wolfram language
no i'm saying i don't call it a vector
it's not a vector it's a list of
symbolic expressions right
that's what you're telling me a symbolic
question
okay all right so the basic point is
this is a list of lists of
of constraints here right right now
these sets
no no not quite this is 50 and the other
50
is that in later ones you can only use
things you haven't
that were earlier used okay
it cannot be recursive i understand i
understand i understand so it's a
sequence okay so what we've got here
there are two things so first of all i
could have turned this
list into that thing equals equals that
ampersand ampersand circle two equals
that is that correct
uh i believe so okay
so what you're saying is you're using
i personally don't think this is the
right design okay i think
that to represent this sequence of
things what you've got here
you have taken a list here to represent
an
ending of a bunch of constraints right
uh yes yes yes
in a word yes yeah but remember
like solve for many other functions too
right
um but let's solve yeah you
would you just solve yes yes many many
things do that
right many many yes go ahead um
so these all you know appears
constraints but there could also just be
you know if you just want to draw or you
know draw a triangle it would still be
true so what stage okay so i can put
that
so to my mind this would be
you know to my mind this should be an
outer wrapper of construction or
geometric construction
and then it has a list of stages of the
geometric construction
and each stage
is what you would otherwise have you
know each
that each stage is something you put
down
in these different steps yeah but why
something completely different from
graphics right
in graphics you can have a flat list or
you can have nested lists of
things they're all drawn at the same
time whereas this has
a control if we have they're not no
they're they're drawn in layers right
the labels
i know that if we had a layer construct
in graphics which we don't have
in graphics every list of sub-lists is
flattened in what's drawn
we could have a layer construct where we
actually put
separate layers in the graphics which we
can cycle through
and maybe we will eventually have such a
construct but we don't have that right
now
right now graphics flattens this on the
other hand does not flatten which i
think is a mistake
i think what we should do is within each
of these sub
cases you know it should in fact flatten
in other words if i put a third level of
list here it shouldn't
you know it shouldn't get confused it
should just flatten it
yeah it it uh you're right it uh it
cannot applies
so yes you could do that right but so so
the point is that this
outer list in a geometric scene
is representing something different than
it was elsewhere now perhaps
this geometric scene should be turned
into geometric construction
that outer wrapper should be geometric
construction in which case
it's expecting you know two levels of
lists
steps that to me makes sense
so it's just a dramatic scene it's just
a subset
well each step then is
you know what do you mean it's still a
geometric scene
i mean you're saying every geometric
construction is also a dramatic scene
but not every geometric scene is
constructive
right right but a gym no by by by which
you mean
that a geometric construction is
essentially backtracking from its end
result
because that's what it knows you know
like its position of its its a b and c
is determined by what the end result
will be right
uh no no the a b it's yeah it's the
opposite it actually can
it does the first step first and then it
fixes i i i'm aware
i'm aware but if i move this around here
okay then whatever b dot a
does is determined by where a would be
in this final picture
right like if i move a and b
independently okay if i move a
and i move b see b moved there
mysteriously
because it's not a fixed point i i
understand that
but what's happening here conceptually
is
the future is reaching back and changing
the past
see what i'm saying the future here
right now i just have an a and a b on
the screen okay
so how come when i move the a the b
suddenly moves
well the answer is because in the future
it knows something has changed
see what i'm saying so that's not a
geometric scene behavior
i don't think that's true no that's no
reason
the reason be is i'll just get into the
guts of what the code's doing here
um just look at the first line
you enforce calendar that they have
yeah if you moved a in a circle so that
you maintained the distance d
then it would i say okay okay fine
fine fine fine fine so you say no one at
that stage
that is not reaching from the future
correct
it's not never it only goes forward
that is this multi-step thing is like
one day we may have graphics layers
for example you still hear me yeah yeah
um the um
um
i really don't think it's the same i
think it's a terrible mistake
to have these different levels of list
you know the first level of list
represents one thing
in this particular case but how would i
know well how would i know
how would i know whether this is if i
put a flatten in here
right then suddenly magically it's going
to be
you know a uh not a construction right
right well if you put flatten around the
matrix it's suddenly not a matrix i
understand that i understand that
i think though that that what we're
expecting with graphics what i'm
imagining here
is that let's say i have a lemma
effectively a lemma will come in a list
and i go plop and put the lemma in here
and then i have to go and do weird
flattening to make sure the lemma
doesn't
con doesn't create itself as a sub
construction
and let me also ask you the question if
i were to have this list
let me show you an example and ask you
what an earth it's going to do
see i'm telling you i i knew there was
something wrong here let me show you
something
okay hello hello let's look at this
thing here
what exactly does that do uh it'll
canonicalize um uh
so if it if it sees any stub list
it says it uh will recognize it's
supposed to be construction
and any naked uh consecutive
naked um okay we're we're
as as we used to say in um
when i think tomican jones was
responsible for this it's the
the concept of pumps as soon as you
start to say and it then does this in
order to save itself from doing that
it's like
the boat is sinking and you're pumping
water out at an increasing rate
okay it's my unfair characterization of
that of that activity
um right and let me point out another
issue
and maybe this is this is a i guess a
slightly separate
issue but right all three of those
points are currently fixed right
so you can't actually move this
or can you no you can't can't you can't
move it at this at the final step
um right at all because those two are
fixed
but if you go to how did they get fixed
what
how did they get fixed are they fixed
because of the nature of the
construction
they're fixed uh
because they were introduced in a
previous step so if you want to unfix
them you can this is just the initial
value
because this step no longer has things
that can move
because the things were reaching from
the past and you would have had to go
back to the past and move them is that
correct
or you could unfix them no not you
i i understand what you're saying but
but you're you are choosing
to fix them in this step
because they are fixed yes but they
weren't fixed by me the user in the past
they're only fixed they are in the the
past light cones so to speak i mean that
they are
they're you know these points had
you know they came from earlier in the
construction but i don't know why that
makes them any more fixed at this stage
than they would otherwise be
okay i can get rid of that that's just
it doesn't seem useful yeah it doesn't
seem useful to fix
just because just because it happened to
come from an earlier point in the
construction doesn't seem useful
i strongly think we should have a
concept of geometric construction as
well as geometric scene
then i feel like it should be geometric
scene should be flipped around the
construction
um right i mean i think if you want to
say
that the second argument should be a
geometric construction rather than
a negative list then
i'd be fine with that if you guys want
to do that
um that's fine
i mean if you think that's more
consistent than having the outer wrap
would be geometric construction
i'm fine with that so you think the
second argument of dramatic scene
just is the construction i think so
but then basically it's a geometric
construction that you can't
easily take out because you lose
information about the variables
yeah yeah i think that's wrong i i think
you should substitute geometric
construction for geometric scene i think
it
i think it also at the top level of
people trying to understand what's going
on i think that will help
i think it will be less obscure to do
that
you basically have two document sets of
documentation and a little bit easier
yeah that's what i think and plus i
think it advertises the fact that you
can do a construction
unit converting currency convert every
currency is also unit so it works also
in
unit convert but currency right so so
then the ques
so i mean one of the advantages
well if you will uh
do does i guess what
what would be the interpretation of the
list in in
so is each element of the list then
its own step and if you want multiple
things in one step you have to let's
wrap them in list
each element of the list in a geometric
construction
each element of the list would be a step
in the construction yes
and i would also would like to argue
that you should allow
an association in a geometric
instruction so that you can label the
steps
with names um
yeah we discussed this once i think
right uh so
question for the uh if each element
in the geometry construction is its own
step sometimes you want to introduce
you know two things at once and it would
be awkw
you know awkward to use the double
ampersand if
say well it's good to have lists right
yeah you can have sublist there's no
problem with that just the ultra level
lifts and geometric construction
means the series of steps in the
construction which could also be
an association with named steps in the
construction
i see and if you want to group things
together you just make it a sub list but
you make it sublist but then okay i see
the semantics of the sub list
is identical to the semantics of the
geometric scene sublist
right okay
um okay now
uh okay these fixed quantities
um
uh brian on the livestream this point
saying there's no reason the point
should be movable and fourth stuff
i don't understand that comment i don't
see why they shouldn't be movable at any
step
um but i also want to know this fixed
quantities how do i even know there is a
quantity involved in this
because you listed this you listed it
i i can see that i listed in the code
i'm asking in the picture
how can i see anything um you
can't see the quantities you just have
to look at uh look at the input
there should probably be a line on the a
b
to indicate that it's a given length
yes i would think so um
so not all quantities are going to be
something that has a
they don't they're not required to be
what's an example uh something which
doesn't have
a semi-major axis or or even the radius
it could be
it could just be length of a b plus
length of
bc something like that it doesn't have
to be something you can
um all it all okay
i i strongly think that you know
thinking about this as a presentation
i think it should say somewhere here i
mean what
in previously you've had these things
what what what happened to that pull
down at the top
that existed in 12-2
that was only when you had conclusions
yeah
uh if you want to see what it looks like
with conclusions you can automatically
run find geometric injectors from that
upper right hand corner
right that was only if you had
conclusions um
if you go back by the way by the way i'd
like to point out
that the fact that
geometric scene here just produces a
plain thing without any crud around it
is really nice well the that was an
issue because it's not actually a
graphics it's only displaying as a
graphics and people
think it's a graphics
it's a geometric scene object if you
want a graphics
in 12 2 years ugly okay this is ugly
i mean we've got to do better than this
this is this this looks like
a you know a 1980
you know terminal you know the window
interface
type thing oh i disagree this this looks
like
many of our competitors like gio gabriel
geometry expressions that basically
if they were built in the 1980s so let's
do better yeah they were not built in
the 1980s
right geogebra is what
15 years old at most okay whatever i
don't really right but it's
showing the tools and it's used in
basically every high school in the
country so yeah i i don't care
it's not that it's not what we're going
for here what we need to do is to make
sure that this actually looks
you know this the fact that we don't
have anybody from design here is
disappointing
right we need to make sure that this
actually looks good and has good ux
i mean you guys are used to doing
algorithmic development
this is a piece of you know this is
something that has direct interface with
ux
and we need to make sure that that part
of it is done properly
and um
um
i i'm not saying the current interface
is perfect because
i've had my own criticisms of it but uh
it can't it can't be sort of a naked
graphics because
it's not fair enough okay okay fine it
can have some border but it needs to be
a better looking border
also if you do want to make if you do
want an actual graphics
i know i saw it i saw it it's in the top
right hand corner i saw that
right and yeah so why why don't you ask
for uh
what is it uh find conjectures there we
go
right so that's the conclusion if you
can construct that
regular and we have uh we have uh
we have a branch i'm not quite sure why
it hasn't been
merged yet uh which sort of improves the
formatting of
those conclusions to look more like the
way people would expect them to look
you mean a traditional form type
formatting
yes right it would like right it would
uh
like that's polygon is actually a
triangle right so would say you know
triangle abc acb is regular or something
like that
i see okay although although if you
paste
these i mean this ux isn't right either
i mean this should have some mechanism
so that you can see that you can paste
this i mean
you know if possible some kind of thing
one hover
that allows you to have a paste here and
then it should paste
in its standard form absolutely
yeah because certainly the the formatted
form doesn't
preserve any of the interpretation and
right
so if we could have a mouse over here i
mean a hover effect
that has a you know a copy button that
would be good
copy is there a interface
element that does that not inside the
menu but it could be next to the menu
okay okay that's fine
um okay so
i don't understand why this says
conclusion here it says find conjectures
i just got a conclusion well that's the
conclusion
because the conclusion might not be true
well which one is it is it a conclusion
or is it a conjecture
the third argument of a geometric scene
is a conclusion the function
find conjectures will produce
conclusions that may or may not be true
that's why there's also going to be a
proof function
and then the conclusions will be true
conclusions
sorry say it again so so you say find
conjectures attempts to find
i mean but it's going to label this as a
conclusion even though it's only a
conjecture is that true or is that
i'm confused here yeah to what extent
does it know it's correct
it um it's just numerical evidence from
from this picture
so not much evidence okay i wonder if
you should
i wonder if we should change that to
assertion which is
more neutral right it might be true it
might not be true but we are
this is what this picture is asserting
right i think that would be much better
one example where it might fail is
a b c d all equidistant that's not
possible
i don't understand that comment but i i
would never come to this conclusion
right so i want to know as a practical
matter
have we ever seen it get something wrong
um i think in some degenerate cases we
have seen let's
generate let's try and generate those so
we understand what the limits are
because you know presumably there is a
way to do this
just like we do for algebraic numbers
and so on where we can use interval
arithmetic and things like that and
never be wrong
no because we don't have good enough
high precision constrained optimization
to us to
get enough digits
but can't we bound them i mean so in
other words if we know it's not
degenerate we know it's correct
i think that's incorrect you could
probably do something like
the distance between a and b is 1 and
the distance between a and c is 1 plus
10 to the minus 10 to the 10 million and
we would never ever find it we come to
the conclusion today
so is this the concern i mean this is
the tom hales problem
basically of of being able to bound
constrained optimizations
is that a true statement and the proof
of the kepler conjecture that was
it's it there's definitely some relation
to it
okay and only that in his one
it's a well-defined problem it's not
that somebody can
up at a bit very small quantity
somewhere randomly no i understand you
have spheres of
of known size i see so your point is if
i go here
and i say um
oh well how could i do this in this
particular case i mean let me let me try
actually in this
can i do it with in inversion in
in version um uh 12.1
uh if you run find geometric conjectures
that's and
i understand i understand i understand
that point i'm trying to make a
geometric
scene that helped me out here i want to
make something where i can put in a 10
to the minus 10 or something
as a um uh let's say i i
violate the triangular quality by one
part and ten to the one hundred
are you are you going to say that things
like that i would not be able to pick up
here
okay but as a practical matter
how would we how could we tell that
have we really thought this through i
mean do we know that it's not possible
to because here will be a perfectly fine
conclusion
we decided that it's true we decided
it's false
and we don't know i mean
like with the prover and some other
technology that
dan is working on we might have a chance
but it might take a long time to verify
it
because now the prover is working by
turning this stuff into algebraic
represent actually not but dense new
machinery is working on algebraic
which which will theoretically come to a
clear conclusion but it might take hours
because these things are turning into
algebraic equations which might be very
very complicated
boy it's amazing you could manage to do
this stuff two thousand years ago
isn't it i don't know i think it is
i'm impressed um
i mean for this one probably it doesn't
take hours but you can keep it
up yes right well the question is
whether in euclid
um okay
so ethan is asking why a big focus on
middle school math
because it's an on-ramp if we can't do
middle school math we certainly can't do
more advanced geometry
plus there are a lot of middle schoolers
ah
and the number of people knowing about
triangle is much bigger than the number
knowing about
stratified spaces or something like this
indeed i mean i think the you know
euclid euclidean geometry has been a
thing for 2000 years
um also triangles are really important
for computers
just ask your computer does it no right
i'm just sorry i'm i'm
okay let's come back to this so
first of all i think this should say
assertion not conclusion
i mean technically another possibility
would be proposition because
propositions are allowed to be force
where theorems are not
the geometric scene itself is like the
proposition
oh because of the conditions right
right yeah because we refer to the
second argument as hypotheses and the
third
as conclusions so so maybe it should say
here find conjectured assertions or
something
yeah make it less less confusing what's
going on i'm a i'm a fan of not having
conjectures and conclusions
so but i mean what we've called the
function find geometric
exactly so i agree with renaming
assertions
but in this case but but then saying so
then it would be fine
find conjectured assertions which then
uh
deals with the i think find geometric
conjectures is fine
well that's the name of the function
right right i think steven's talking
about
on this drop down menu because we're not
changing the name of the function
presumably
right right so but right now
we aren't tracking the source of the uh
the conclusion but it might have been
supplied by find geometric conjectures
but it may also have come from
our ep table it may be the conclusion of
a
theorem from euclid the user can also
put it in manually if they want
right and there it can be
blatantly wrong if you want right oh yes
yes
that is the easiest way to get what's
the case what's the case where it came
out of our actual
um theorem bank so to speak
when does that how does that happen so
for example entity geometric scene
euclid book one proposition one
the the third argument will be the
conclusion so if i say geometric scene
and i say in here what do i just say i
say euclid
book one that won't work but
get the entity
okay so if i say entity geometric scene
euclid book one
proposition yep ten
so you want to take the scene property
from the entity
oh i see so so this is in fact not what
i'm doing here
so if i say scene from this
okay now what
so now do random instance
but there's no theorem here this is
still again
that's a third argument yeah the third
argument is the theorem
it's that d is the midpoint
by the way the fact that we display the
dots here seems wrong to me
i think we should we should d dot them
[Music]
oh i so like being able to resize this i
really like being able to resize this
to real loss here to not be able to do
that
i i guess we can't do that is that true
because of the way that the plus minus
and things works
um no i think i i don't see
uh why we couldn't we don't get it for
free
but it might be yeah but certainly
putting this thing on
on the right here um
dragging at the edges differently from
dragging elsewhere
right well okay all right that's
implementation but but let's talk about
this here
so this is an assertion but this is
actually a bona fide conclusion
which we know because it's in the third
argument um
well we know it's true because we
curated it
right fine i understand so what i'm
suggesting then is that we have a third
line here
which is and by the way i just don't
think this ux is right for the steps
here
because that's the whole does it does it
bring up the conclusion on all steps so
does that only come up on the last step
i don't know why does it bring it up
um
why does it bring it up there should it
bring it up there or not well i i could
get rid of it i mean it won't be i want
to know what i i don't care about the
implementation i just want to know
does it make sense for it to bring up
the conclusion if it is really a
conclusion
on step two of the of the construction
i would say yes because it's a different
argument it's a different element of the
whole
thing i mean you might want to study
like
how it comes together but you still want
to see what by the end you get
okay fine all right but then but then
assertion is a different story right
when we when we say find
the um uh find conjectured assertions
that should come up in a different line
than something where you bring up
just this uh
you know conclusion which here is
unlabeled and probably here should be
unlabeled as well
so then geometric the geometric scene
object would need to
have two lines things yeah two lines so
one would be labeled assertions
for it well i'm saying structurally
the that we would need to maintain two
separate lists
inside the geometrical object so yes but
but i mean
what exactly would the difference be
one is supposed to be certified to be
true
but who who does this notification right
right
the user could just put garbage in there
fair enough fair enough so so you're
saying
the fine conjectures thing is creating a
geometric scene object with three
arguments
yep yeah and you could feed this to find
geometric proof
if you want a proof of it
okay
um you know proving based math is such a
mess compared to computational math
i'm sorry i just had to say that with
all these things about what comes out
what goes in
proofs assertions et cetera et cetera i
mean this was the way people
you know just because it was done that
way for 2000 years doesn't mean it's the
right way to do it
sorry i just had to make that
editorialized comment
um i mean we're just seeing how messy
this is of
you know
i mean it's also to me a little bit the
fact that we can display these
assertions here but we cannot display
the symbolic form of the
i mean i guess otherwise we have no
other way the way we're displaying the
symbolic form of the main event
is through this actual construction you
know through this actual graphic here
right i mean this this stuff here is
turning into this graphic
it's merely this part at the end here
that it's not but there are certainly
things that could be said in this
graphic
and that's exactly yes yes yes this is
why it's confused
look if i put a constraint euclidean
distance between
you know ac plus cb equals seven or
something
right i would not see that anywhere and
that's wrong
i should as much see that constraint in
some line at the top as i see this
conclusion in some line at the top
you see what i'm saying
they're things that i can see on the
picture they're things that i cannot see
on the picture
right do you understand what i'm saying
the things that i can't see on the
picture like this one here
i should be displaying at the top
right so we actually need another
i am not convinced about this there are
definitely cases where i
i agree it's true but i think there will
be as many cases where the statement is
not
in the one on the left where we just use
for convenient
labels of things like circle one circle
two
you can't see circle one that divert
circle one and the equality to a circle
and i don't think we want to have all of
this well i agree with the quality
statement i i agree so that them
what statements do we want to have we
can probably decide what statements we
want to have and maybe by default
they're not shown
but there's a way to get them shown
i think that's another thing we need
here okay we are deeply running out of
time i'm
i've had a terrible um
yeah we're really deeply running out of
time um
um so so for some of the interfacing aka
i'm not quite sure
who would be our user interface experts
for such things
i think well noah and jeremy are the
right people probably
um and uh
i think we're going to need to come back
and look at this again i mean this is
very nice stuff
very nice stuff um
i'm concerned about
yeah okay uh
what else should i be looking at here as
we just in the last minute or so here
um
yeah go ahead i was gonna say see how
you like the look of
hide controls
i changed size for some reason
okay i like the fact that you can go
like that and
and click it to get back the controls
at least i think i like that but the
fact that you have that as a click thing
means that i can't resize for example as
soon as i try to resize
it's going to uh go into the show
controls mode
right lou how difficult is it to resize
a
generic dynamic module like the
um to resize a dynamic module well i
mean there there are
constructs like pain that give you an
arbitrary resize handle
on anything um right i think uh
i i forget what i think this is okay you
guys need to talk about this but i'm not
i don't need to be part of this
okay there um uh
all right well we should probably wrap
this up
right now but um
uh i think there's a little bit of
iteration to be done
but it's very beautiful and
uh um anything else you need from me
right now
doesn't seem like it all right to be
continued
you guys soon thanks thanks to folks on
the live stream
okay see you all later thank you